bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'une expérience fondamentale de la
mécanique quantique qui illustre à elle
seule plusieurs aspects essentiels et
contre-intuitif du monde quantique il
s'agit de l'expérience de Stern et
guerlar du nom des deux physiciens
allemands qui l'ont réalisé pour la
première fois il y a presque un siècle
en 1922 quand on pense aux expériences
fondatrices de la mécanique quantique on
pense souvent en premier aux expériences
d'interférences avec des électrons en
utilisant les fentes Djang et c'est vrai
qu'elles permettent de capturer de façon
très visuelle beaucoup d'aspects de la
mécanique quantique d'ailleurs je vous
renvoie à la vidéo que j'avais faite sur
le sujet mais l'expérience de Stern et
guerlar dont on va parler aujourd'hui
est tout aussi importante et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'elle permet
d'illustrer certains phénomènes
quantiques sous un angle différent et
donc très complémentaire de ce qu'on
peut voir avec les expériences
d'interférences ce que je vais vous
présenter ici est une version un peu
idéalisée modernisée de l'expérience
telle qu'on pourrait la refaire
aujourd'hui avec des moyens
expérimentaux meilleurs que ceux dont
disposaient les deux physiciens
allemands il y a un siècle imaginez
qu'on dispose d'une boîte percée d'un
petit trou et que par ce trou soit émis
un faisceau de particules dans
l'expérience d'origine il s'agissait
d'atomes d'argent qui sortait d'un fou
mais en fait la nature exacte des
particules pourrait être différente sur
la trajectoire du faisceau on va placer
un champ magnétique bien uniforme et
derrière un écran pour repérer à quel
endroit viennent taper les particules
alors qu'est-ce qui va se passer
vous peut-être qu'un champ magnétique ça
agit sur les particules chargées il y a
une formule pour ça qui exprime la force
exercée c'est la force de Lorent et on
voit dans cette formule que si la
particule n'est pas chargée et il n'y
aura pas de force facile donc si on fait
comme jeter un égard et qu'on utilise
des atomes qui sont donc globalement
neutres le champ magnétique n'a pas
d'effet et donc toutes les particules
viennent taper au centre de l'écran
qu'on a placé oui alors je n'ai pas dit
mais dans cette trajectoire on peut
ignorer les effets de la gravité les
particules dans le faisceau ont une
vitesse importante plusieurs centaines
de mètres par seconde et donc elles sont
à peine affectées le temps du trajet
jusqu'ici rien d'incroyable maintenant
variante on va utiliser un champ
magnétique qui n'est plus uniforme mais
qui est par exemple le plus fort en haut
qu'en bas et ce de façon progressive on
parle d'un champ magnétique avec un
gradient
et là quand on fait l'expérience bah
première surprise on constate que les
particules sont déviées par ce champ
magnétique si le champ magnétique est
dirigé selon l'axe vertical appelons le
laxe Z les particules vont être déviées
certaines vers le haut et d'autres vers
le bas à première vue ça peut être
étonnant on l'a dit les atomes sont
neutres on ne s'attendons pas à ce qu'il
soit sensible au champ magnétique
pourquoi quand le champ magnétique n'est
plus uniforme cela provoque une
déviation et bien c'est ce qui se
passerait si au lieu de balancer des
atomes on balançait des petits aimants
si vous prenez un aimant je vais
représenter ça avec l'image familière
des pôles Nord et Sud et que vous
l'envoyez ainsi dans un champ magnétique
non uniforme qui a un gradient et bien
l'aimant va être dévié c'est un effet
magnétique bien connu et l'intensité de
la déviation va dépendre de deux choses
la puissance de l'aimant et son
orientation par rapport à l'axe de
variation du champ ici l'axe vertical Z
si vous alignez l'épaule dans l'axe de
la trajectoire ils sont perpendiculaires
laxe Z et il n'y aura pas de déviation
et sinon la déviation sera vers le bas
ou vers le haut suivant l'orientation
dans notre cas les déviations maximales
sont obtenues quand l'aimant est
parfaitement aligné avec la direction de
variation du champ
évidemment tout ça est aussi
proportionnel à la taille et à la force
de l'aimant un aimant plus puissant
serait dévié de façon plus importante
pour représenter cette combinaison des
caractéristiques de l'aimant et de son
orientation on utilise une quantité
physique qu'on appelle le moment
magnétique de l'aimant c'est un vecteur
et on s'en sert pour représenter
l'aimant à l'aide d'une flèche qui
pointe vers son pôle Nord et qui est
d'autant plus longue que l'aimant est
puissant
on va noter ce vecteur m comme moment
magnétique avec cette représentation
pour savoir à quel point l'aimant est
dévié ce qu'on va regarder c'est
simplement la composante de ce vecteur
sur l'axe Z cette quantité ici on note
cette composante MZ m est un vecteur
mais MZ est juste un nombre réel positif
ou négatif pour des aimants à peu près
alignés avec l'axe Z MZ sera importante
et on aura une forte déviation vers le
haut ou vers le bas et dans le cas
perpendiculaire la composante MZ est
nulle et on aura pas de déviation alors
voilà tout ça c'est pour des aimants
dont on connaît le moment magnétique m
et donc revenons à l'expérience de Stern
et hirlar si on constate que les atomes
qu'on envoie dans ce champ magnétique
sont aussi déviés et bien ça signifie
simplement qu'il se comporte comme des
aimants c'est quelque chose qui n'était
pas forcément inattendu à l'époque
c'était même ce qu'espérait voir Stern
et garlard mais il y a eu une surprise
de taille si les atomes se comportaient
effectivement comme des petits aimants
qui possèdent un moment magnétique on
peut s'a répondre à ce que quand il
Sorte de la boîte pour former le
faisceau l'orientation de leur moment
magnétique soit quelconque qu'il y en
ait dans tous les sens d'ailleurs ici je
le représente seulement en 2D pour faire
simple mais il faudrait même le faire en
3D et comme la déviation va dépendre de
l'orientation on devrait détecter des
impacts un peu partout sur l'écran au
centre en haut en bas en fonction de
l'orientation de nos atomes
on peut même en principe deviner la
répartition des impacts pas mal d'impact
au centre moins quand on va vers les
extrêmes et puis pas du tout au-delà
d'un certain seuil sauf que ça n'est pas
du tout ce que je ternes garlard ont
observé au lieu de ça ils ont constaté
que les impacts formaient deux tâches
bien localisées en haut et en bas et
rien au centre ça rend très bizarre on
l'a dit normalement pour un aimant la
déviation est liée à MZ la composante du
moment magnétique sur l'axe vertical
donc dans l'expérience c'est comme si
les particules avaient effectivement un
moment magnétique mais que sa composante
MZ ne puisse prendre que deux valeurs
bien définies et opposées l’une positive
l'autre négative mais aucune des valeurs
intermédiaires et en particulier c'est
jamais zéro ou presque
à partir de la position des deux tâches
et en utilisant les caractéristiques de
l'expérience sa taille la vitesse des
particules le champ magnétique etc on
pourrait en déduire la valeur du moment
magnétique MZ donc le dispositif qu'on
vient de décrire l'appareil de
sternagura permet de mesurer le moment
magnétique des particules selon un axe
ici MZ alors la valeur exacte qu'on
obtient n'est pas forcément critique ici
l'unité est un peu inhabituelle ce sont
des ampères mètres carrés et donc pour
faire simple on va juste appeler ces
deux valeurs plus un et -1 les
particules qui ont tapé en haut ont un
moment magnétique MZ égal plus un et
celle en bas MZ = - 1
le fait qu'on est uniquement ces deux
valeurs possibles illustrent
parfaitement un phénomène qui est
caractéristique de la mécanique
quantique et qui lui donne même son nom
c'est la quantification il s'agit du
fait que certaines propriétés des objets
quantiques ici c'est MZ sont quantifiés
elles ne peuvent pas prendre n'importe
quelle valeur en continu comme c'est le
cas classiquement elles sont limitées à
un ensemble de valeurs discrète ici
seulement deux valeurs possibles - 1 et
plus un vous savez peut-être que c'est
le genre de phénomène qu'on observe par
exemple avec les niveaux d'énergie de
l'atome d'hydrogène qui sont eux aussi
quantifiés mais là c'est pas un niveau
d'énergie c'est la composante d'un
vecteur selon un certain axe se dire
qu'une grandeur géométrique soit soumise
à cet effet de quantification c'est
quand même carrément bizarre ici le
choix de l'axe Z est totalement
arbitraire j'aurais pu prendre n'importe
quoi d'autre et j'aurais trouvé plus un
ou moins un quel que soit l'axe alors
géométriquement ça n'a vraiment aucun
sens essayez de me dessiner un vecteur
dont la composante selon n'importe quel
axe soit toujours plus un ou moins un
alors on va essayer de creuser cette
idée mais avant ça un point important
pour la suite si on ne met pas d'écran
pour visualiser les impacts ce qu'il se
passe c'est qu'on sépare simplement le
faisceau initial en deux faisceaux en
fonction de la valeur de MZ vers le haut
le faisceau MZ = + 1 et vers le bas MZ =
- 1
maintenant si on utilise un deuxième
appareil identique qu'on le place sur
chacun des deux faisceaux et bien là on
ne verra plus de séparation les
particules qui étaient initialement
dédiées vers le haut vont tout à nouveau
être déviés vers le haut et pareil pour
celles qui étaient dédiée vers le bas
c'est logique on l'a dit dans cette
expérience on peut voir le dispositif
comme un appareil de mesure il permet de
connaître la valeur de MZ de savoir si
c'est moins un ou plus un et de trier
les particules donc si on répète la
mesure et bien on obtient à nouveau la
même déviation c'est quand même un peu
rassurant et donc tout ça laisse penser
que dans notre faisceau initial il y
avait des atomes à MZ = + 1 et d'autres
à MZ = -1 et qu'on les a séparés en deux
grâce au dispositif
bon maintenant on l'a dit tout ça
concerne la composante selon l'axe
vertical Z mais le vecteur moment
magnétique bah il a évidemment d'autres
composantes sur les autres axes
considérons par exemple l'axe Y celui
qui serait perpendiculaire au plan de la
figure on peut réaliser un dispositif
qui va mesurer la composante m y il
suffit de changer la direction de
variation du champ magnétique et si on
fait ça on observe exactement la même
chose une séparation en deux faisceaux
un pour My égal plus un et un pour mig
égale - 1 et on pourrait faire pareil
avec l'axe X mais bon faisons simple
restons en deux dimensions
prix littéralement ces résultats
semblent dire que le vecteur moment
magnétique aime ne peut prendre que 4
valeurs suivant que my et MZ valent
moins un ou plus un c'est ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer
mais ce qui est bizarre on l'a dit c'est
que géométriquement ça n'a aucun sens on
pourrait penser avec ça que le vecteur m
est toujours aligné sur la diagonale des
axes Y et Z sauf qu'ici les axes YZ sont
complètement arbitraires ils ont été
choisis pour l'expérience on aurait pu
lui choisir tourner de 10 20 ou 30
degrés et en fait on aurait eu
exactement les mêmes résultats pour s'en
sortir il faut renoncer à interpréter le
moment magnétique m comme un vecteur
géométrique normal dont les composantes
sur les différents axes comme my ou MZ
aurait une valeur bien définie et pour
le voir on va utiliser une nouvelle
variante du montage
prenons un premier appareil qui sépare
donc les deux faisceaux selon MZ donc
qui mesure MZ puis installons derrière
le même mais pour mesurer my puis enfin
à nouveau une mesure de NZ on l'a dit
normalement quand on mesure 2 fois de
suite la même quantité on obtient le
même résultat mais en fait pas ici si
par exemple on ne regarde que le
faisceau initial MZ égal plus un pour
faire simple après le premier appareil
on s'attendrait quand on le remesure
avec le troisième appareil après la
mesure de y qu'on est toujours
uniquement des MZ égal plus un mais en
fait non on trouve à nouveau deux
faisceaux correspondant à MZ égal plus
un et MZ = -1 on croyait avoir déterminé
la valeur de MZ après le premier
appareil et sélectionner uniquement les
particules MZ = + 1 mais le fait de
mesurer leur mig juste après a
complètement brouillé les cartes et
rendu leur valeur de MZ complètement
indéterminée
on peut interpréter ça grâce à la notion
de superposition quantique qu'on a
évoqué dans une vidéo précédente en
sortie du premier appareil si on garde
uniquement le faisceau du haut tous les
atomes ont une valeur unique bien
définie pour MZ on dit qu'ils sont dans
un état propre de MZ propre ça veut dire
en gros qu'il n'y a pas de phénomène de
superposition quantique pour cette
quantité de façon similaire le deuxième
appareil mesure ensuite my donc il va
mettre les atomes dans un état propre de
My soit my 1 soit my égale plus un mais
pas une superposition des deux mais ce
qu'on constate avec le troisième
appareil c'est que les particules ne
sont plus dans un état propre de MZ même
si après la première mesure on avait
gardé que celle qui était MZ égal plus
un et bien on obtient à nouveau deux
faisceaux MZ égal plus un et MZ = - 1
on l'interprète en disant qu'à cause de
la mesure de My les particules sont
revenues dans un état superposé pour MZ
en sortie de la mesure my chaque
particules est dans un état qui est une
superposition de MZ également-1 et MZ =
+ 1 et le passage dans le troisième
appareil va renforcer l'une ou l'autre
de ses possibilités pour chaque partie
on voit avec cette seule expérience
plusieurs caractéristiques importantes
des systèmes quantiques tout d'abord la
mesure affecte irrémédiablement l'état
du système en le mettant dans un état
propre de la quantité qu'on mesure mais
surtout cette notion d'état propre ou
son contraire l’état superposé n’est pas
absolue elle est relative elle dépend de
la quantité qu'on mesure ici quand la
valeur MZ est connue on est dans un état
propre pour MZ mais qui s'avère être un
état superposé pour My et réciproquement
en sortie du deuxième appareil on a un
état propre pour émy mais qui en est un
superposer pour MZ
impossible d’être dans un état propre
pour les deux quantités à la fois on dit
que les deux quantités ne commutent pas
ou que leur mesure ne commutent pas vous
savez en Mac la commutativité c'est
quand l'ordre de l'opération n'a pas
d'importance l'addition est commutative
parce que A + B = B + A et idem pour la
multiplication mais par exemple la
soustraction ou la division ne sont pas
des opérations communitatives ici les
mesures des composantes du moment
magnétique ne commutent pas si on mesure
MZ on ne sait plus rien sur My et
réciproquement l'ordre a donc son
importance alors vous noterez que ça
ressemble furieusement à ce qu'on
appelle ailleurs le principe
d'incertitude de Heisenberg ce principe
nous dit notamment que quand la position
d'une particule est parfaitement
déterminée sa vitesse ne l'est plus du
tout et réciproquement et que plus on
connaît l'une moins on connaît l'autre
et bien ce principe d'incertitude est en
fait plus général ça n'est pas seulement
la position et la vitesse dès qu'on a
deux propriétés physiques dont les
mesures ne commutent pas elles sont
soumises à une relation du même type
connaître Z rend my complètement
indéterminé et réciproquement
vous voyez donc que bien qu'elle soit
moins connue que l'expérience
d'interférence avec des électrons
l'expérience de Stern et guerlard permet
d'illustrer de façon assez minimale
plusieurs principes de la mécanique
quantique la quantification la
superposition l'impact d'une mesure sur
l'état du système et une forme de
principe d'incertitude alors pour être
complet il faudrait creuser encore
l'interprétation de cette expérience et
expliquer en quoi elle a aussi permis de
mettre en évidence un concept très
important la notion de spin mais cette
interprétation n'a appris corps que
quelques années après l'expérience
initiale et je vais garder ça pour un
prochain épisode voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui comme toujours deux ou trois
compléments sont à retrouver sur le blog
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et de
mettre la satanée cloche pour ne rien
rater des prochains épisodes de la
chaîne sur la mécanique quantique ou sur
autre chose et moi je vous dis à très
vite pour une prochaine vidéo à bientôt
[Musique]